[Music]
salma hayek wrote a revealing op-ed in
the new york times back in december
about what she claimed we're disturbing
experiences with Harvey Weinstein and
she's revealing to Oprah why she stayed
silent for so long I was ashamed that I
didn't do speak up and then when so many
women came out this is a strange
sensation
I felt like my pain was so small because
there were so many that also had the
same thing when other actresses came
forward with their claims of abuse by
Weinstein Salma was at first hesitant to
share her own story there is a moment
and I think it's human and I was like
well there's no point for me to talk
because it just happens to everyone you
know and I felt that by itself it was
just my own little drama Salma says
Weinstein bullied and threatened her
during filming of her 2002 film Frida
alleging Weinstein said to the film's
director quote I'm going to break the
kneecaps of that expletive today
Weinstein's rep tells et quote this
comment does not reflect how he feels
about her he doesn't recall ever saying
such an awful thing
Salman sit down was for Oprah's
supersoul conversations the actress says
she feels empowered that women binding
together will make a difference it's
about becoming part of something that
can make the big change happen
you